من مقرها الشهير في كابورتينو بولايه
كاليفورنيا كشفت شركه التكنولوجيا
العملاقه ابل عن منتج طال انتظاره وتوقعه
لسنوات
اشاد الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه ابل تيم كوك
بوصول النظاره الذكيه في اعلان مسجل مسبقا
وقال انها ستشكل نقطه تحول في صناعه اجهزه
الواقع الافتراضي
نوع جديد من اجهزه الكمبيوتر يعزز الواقع
من خلال المزج السادس للعالم الحقيقي
بالعالم الافتراضي انه اول منتج من ابل
تنظر من خلاله ولا تنظر اليه يبدو مالوفا
لكنه جديد تماما يمكنك رؤيه المحتوى
الرقمي والاجتماع اليه والتفاعل معه تماما
كما هي الحال في الفضاء الحقيقي
تهدف الشركه من عرض النظاره فيجن برو الى
ادماج الواقع بالمحتوى الرقمي فيما اطلقت
عليه الواقع المختلط
وستنقل النظاره الذكيه المستخدمين الى ما
تسميه الشركه حوسبه المكانيه لتصفح
الانترنت ومشاهده الافلام والالعاب واجراء
مكالمات الفيديو من بين اشياء اخرى
وستزود النظاره 12
ومجموعه متنوعه من اجهزه الاستشعار تتيح
للمستخدمين التحكم في التطبيقات المختلفه
باعينهم وايماءات ايديهم فقط على الرغم من
ان مسؤولي ابل قدموا عرضا مسبقا شاملا
لقدرات النظاره فان المستهلكين لن يتمكنوا
من الحصول عليها قريبا وقالت
ستباع بالتجزئه مقابل ثلاثه الاف
واربعمائه وتسعه وتسعين دولارا في اوائل
العام المقبل وستكون متاحه فقط في
الولايات المتحده في البدايه
اعتقد ان من سيقتنيها في البدايه هم الناس
الذين يريدون التباهي والاشخاص الذين
يرغبون في الحصول على كل منتج من منتجات
ابل وربما للاثرياء والمشاهير ولكن هذا
كان صحيحا مع ساعات ابل حيث اقبل عليها
عدد قليل جدا من الاشخاص في البدايه وبعد
ذلك اضحى الامر طبيعيا بعد ان اطلقت
اصدارات ارخص
قد تكون برو علامه فارقه اخرى في تقاليد
ابل في اطلاق منتجات فاخره شكلت نقطه تحول
في عالم التكنولوجيا وعلى الرغم من ان
الشركه لم تكن دائما اول من جرب صنع جهاز
معين فانها لا تصدر منتجات جديده الا
عندما يكون من المؤكد انها ستحدث ضجه
كبيره